si vous aimez ce à quoi vous attendre
des super moments de rap la découverte
de nouveaux talents vraiment qu'ils y
présent
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on direction jeu
dans la prison de sept et franck en face
de montrer des films et et un side qui
arrive on est dans un parloir et
abandonné by très déçu à cause de moi
mais j'ai demandé avant c'était possible
premier jour de laëtitia premier jour de
ces tags louis premier jour de l'équipe
effectivement on commence avec une des
scènes les plus compliqués en termes
d'émotions et d'intensité et en plus je
veux rajouter ce moment où saïd
effectivement notre cas son personnage
craché au visage de l'alfa
c'est ultra payant à l'image ça nous
permet plein de choses sur la
détestation qu'on a besoin de porter à
ce personnage et l'empathie qu'on va
avoir pour le personnage de l'alfa mais
c'est vrai que pour laetitia qui était
qui venait d'arriver sur le plateau
c'est assez étonnante
c'est une petite scène qu'on a eue avec
avec brahim c est un genre assez
particulier jour là où c'était scène on
devait vraiment être assez triste et
francky nous à nous a dirigés nous
amener vers des émotions qu'on avait
nous mêmes en nous vraiment activement
saïdou particulièrement été chercher des
choses on lui qui qui transpire à
l'image de manière très étonnante alors
ça concerne la la mort de claude de
clément d'apache à l'image donc pour
nous c'était fantastique d'avoir ça
saïdou nous envoyer une performance
d'acteur et il n'y a pas beaucoup de
comédiens qui sont capables de faire ça
et c'est vrai que c'était un moment très
fort
[Musique]
parfois les gens pensent que la saison
va être plus douce parce que l'héroïne
est une femme alors que cette saison est
plus noir et plus dur j'ai l'impression
que la vie de l'alfa sachant que ben il
a un fils et qui a plein de
complications j'ai l'impression que
c'est bon ça donne dans la saison 2
quelque chose de plus mature c'est vrai
qu'avec apache et toute la bande dans le
quartier les problèmes du quartier les
problèmes durables etc etc là on va plus
se rend très bas dans la vie aussi du
personnage la saison a été validée d'une
force à ces ondes et j'espère qu'elle le
sera tout autant sachant qu'on va
vraiment me
[Musique]
avec la saison 2 ça leur donnera
forcément envie de regarder la série
chers amis qui n'ont pas encore regardé
valider un tout va bien d'abord c'est
sur le my canal pour la vie et puis la
saison 2 arrive donc c'est l'occasion ce
faire
le double qui fait quoi pour la vie pour
la vie away